my wounds and weapons I use them to
crush my opponents you ever hear that
evidence on my words I'm weapons I'm a
Christian my opponents opponents and
bonus the bonus I make the bonus the
bonus the bonus and my bonus and show me
some bonus loans donis my dong dong dong
as a bonus and on them I'm getting bonus
on the PO mr. Jonas upon bonus these
ones and weapons I never show no emotion
even though I'm angry right now what I
mean when I finish I don't show emotions
and don't cry even though one got songs
about crap basically a hypocrite just
like even though I'm crying him I handle
myself like gonna get doesn't disagree
[Music]
every time always sound like he's under
a truck I got bad luck to the drunken
that's junk junk the gun some bad luck
my warns and weapons but they don't help
me now Wow get this trunk on me before
up truck I'm thunk to been assumed that
it's a bad luck I'm gonna be crying but
I never shown almost as even normal man
like the game district man looks eerie
literally I pick up my phone in Serie
says I don't know how to respond to that
and it that's what it says I never I
didn't hit her button she's just like
what the [ __ ] are you doing what are you
doing and you look going cuz I'm bored
I'm on the world tour doesn't matter cuz
don't and I got my pockets fanuc Aziz
fan worst song ever
we're a song of all time this is a fun
funky fun funky episode dude